[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the pleasure doing business with you
Sonny so how long have you been ant-man
again no uh I just sort of happened I
[Music]
seem to mess it up almost every time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch your
back
like a partner
[Music]
dr. Pam I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when he's crazy could be ghosts
like walks through walls to stuff solely
of tech and now supposed to take over
the world or whatever
who would've believed that in your hour
of need you would turn the house at me
because we robbed you do you remember
that's us feeling everybody this video
and man in the wasp teaming up follow my
lead
[Music]
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny I
was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet
you've 65 feet 65 if you two are
finished comparing sizes 65
[Music]